The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RUSS TEDRAKE: OK, welcome back.
So last time, I tried to ease
us into a switch in thinking.
From instead of trying
to explicitly solve
the Hamilton-Jacobi
equation, I wanted
to try thinking about a
different class of algorithms
which we called policy search.
Where you explicitly
parameterize your control
system with some
parameters and then just
search in the space of
parameters for a good solution.
So the idea was, let's
go ahead and define
some class of control systems
by some parameter vector.
And then, our optimal
control problem,
which we called sort of
minimizing J pi of x0 t.
We could think of as
explicitly minimizing over
that vector alpha.
Something that if I shorthand
pi of alpha with just alpha
of x0 t.
And if you're willing to
restrict your thinking
to a single initial
condition, then you
can really just think of it
as, I've got some old function
J of alpha, and I
want to minimize it
with respect to alpha.
That puts you squarely in the
land of you can call fmin.
In MATLAB, you can do sort of
any old optimization on it.
So today, I said the lecture is
called Trajectory Optimization.
I tried to point out that
thinking about this policy
search, that could
be a general thing.
That could encompass
feedback policies.
For instance, this
could be parameterized
by if K is filled out
with alphas, that's OK.
And I also said it could be
open-loop trajectories, right?
In general, I could just ignore
x, and it could just be--
let me see how I
wrote it last time.
It could just be, let's
say, that u at time t
is just alpha of
n where n equals
some floor of to over dt.
I'm not sure that's the
best way to write it,
but that's, I think, a
clean way to write it.
So what does that mean?
That means that my
control policy over time
is just a set of--
it's a zero-order
hold trajectory.
Where each of these are dt long.
And this one is alpha 1, this
one is alpha 2, and so on.
So if I'm willing
to make some sort
of simple tape of trajectories
that are parameterized
by these alphas--
and naturally, you can do
a cleaner job of doing this
with splines or whatever.
But let's think about the
simple representation.
Then solving this
min alpha J alpha
is equivalent to trying to
find the open-loop trajectory
that I'd like to follow which
minimizes J, for instance,
for some initial, for a
particular initial condition.
So that class, this sort
of the open-loop family
of control policies
is special enough
that there's a lot
of methods that
are highly tuned for
that open-loop trajectory
optimization.
So I want to talk about
a few of them today.
They're very powerful.
They tend to scale to fairly
high-dimensional systems.
And I actually think they can
be used as a part of a process
to design good
feedback controllers.
But that's a longer story.
Let me just tell you
today how to solve
open-loop trajectories.
In the trajectory optimization
world, there is roughly--
well, there's lots of ideas.
And so many ideas,
actually, that it's going
to slip into Tuesday I decided.
But let me tell you about
the first two of them today.
I want to talk about
first shooting methods
and then direct
collocation methods.
And we have lots of
half-baked examples
that were coded in the
middle of the night,
so to hopefully bring
the message through.
OK, so what's a shooting method?
You might be able to guess.
Shooting methods are--
how many people know?
How many people know what
shooting methods are?
Excellent, OK.
How would you characterize
a shooting method?
What would you--
AUDIENCE: Can we
integrate the states
from the book from
the beginning time
and the [? co ?] states
from the end time
and hope they match up in
the middle or something?
RUSS TEDRAKE:
Perfect, well, yeah, I
mean, in general, actually so
it's even simpler than that.
In general, so shooting
methods are often
the title for solving
boundary value problems, which
is what you just said.
The name comes from
boundary value problems.
We can use them more
generally, even if it's just
an initial value problem.
But the basic idea is
exactly what you said.
Let's just simulate the
system with the parameters
we have and then work to
change our parameters,
shoot at a little
bit different place.
So let's say we have t over x
for some very simple system.
And I run my controller from
initial conditions here,
and I get some trajectory with
alpha equals 1, let's say,
or even alpha equals
some long vector.
Maybe it's 1, 2, 43, 6.
I get that.
And let's say my goal is to get
my final conditions to be here.
Then, what I'm
going to do is, I'm
going to change alpha
and run it again,
shooting successively until I
get to my desired final value.
If I change alpha, then maybe
my controller gets me here.
And if I change it
again, maybe it'll
get me all the way
up to the goal.
I see you.
AUDIENCE: What's the update?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yeah, OK,
I'll tell you the update.
But the big idea
is, I'm going to I'm
going to try to solve a problem,
for instance, a boundary value
problem, by starting with some
initial conditions simulating
and just changing
the parameters.
So you can imagine, if the thing
you're trying to solve is not--
I mean, a boundary value
problem is obviously
one thing we can do.
But maybe you also
have a cost that you're
trying to optimize over that.
Then the basic idea still holds.
So I told you the first
way to start thinking
about how to do that last time.
We can evaluate J of
alpha pretty easily.
Let me stick with my
superscript alpha notation.
We can evaluate that with just
forward simulation, right?
And if you want to know
how to change alpha,
then it helps to know the
gradients-- partial J,
partial alpha, evaluated
at the current alpha.
I told you one way
to do that last time,
with an adjoint method.
Which I still can't resist
calling back prop through time,
because that's--
I learned it first as
a neural networks guy.
And there's a second way to
do it, which in some cases,
is not less efficient.
But it's certainly easier to
derive and easier to code.
So I want to do that
to make sure we have
the intuition about it too.
It's also useful.
Again, this is the neural
network name for it.
There's probably a good name
from more standard optimization
theory.
But in neural networks, people
call it real-time recurrent
learning, which is RTRL.
And this is BPTT.
So how do we compute J of alpha?
The adjoint method, I told
you that if you simulate
the system forward
in time, you get
the sort of forward equation.
You figure out J. If you then
simulate the adjoint equation
backwards in time,
I called it y.
y dot is some function
going backwards.
You can interpret y as being
the sensitivity of changing--
so let me just write down
the form of it quickly.
So the adjoint,
remember, was x dot
equals f of x going forward.
Did I actually right
down the right equation
for you going backwards?
And then, negative y
dot is f of x y minus G
of x T. Where those are the big
gradient matrices I wrote down
last time, going backwards.
And then, the update gives you,
that partial J partial alpha
is just a simple integral now.
So this backwards
equation, which
happens to be the
adjoint equation we
saw in Pontryagin's
minimum principle. y has
an interpretation
as the sensitivity
of the cost on changing x-- y
at some time T, y at time 3.
It's the same size, the
same dimension as x--
this y variable.
It's a column
vector just like x.
It has the interpretation,
it's the sensitivity
of J on changing x at that time.
So you compute forward, then you
compute back the gradient of J
with respect to x of t.
And then knowing
that, you can simply
compute the full gradient
with respect to the alpha.
And that took a little
bit of derivation
through the Lagrange
multipliers.
RTRL is actually even simpler.
Is it OK if that wall
disappears for a minute?
We wrote that last time, right?
I'm just going to go
to my third wall here.
This time, I'm only
going to simulate forward
in time, which is
why it's called
real-time recurrent learning.
Because some people don't like
having to simulate forward
to capital T and then
simulate all the way
back to make an update.
That's sort of, we have to go
all the way to the end of time
in order to make your
update at time 2.
It's more appealing if you
can make your update at time 2
by just thinking
about time 0 to 2.
So you can do it in
a forward pass only.
The name came from maybe that,
I think, at one point in time,
someone maybe thought maybe
this is what the brain is doing.
Because people thought
the brain can't
be doing these backward
passes efficiently.
So maybe real-time
recurring learning
is what the brain is doing.
But I don't think people
really think that anymore.
There was one paper
that thought that,
which is a nice paper, but--
So let's do, let me
just show you RTRL,
because it turns out to be maybe
even the more simple thing.
So I have J of alpha
starting from x0,
0 is the integral from T.
Oops, I did that again.
Let me come up with a
new working variable.
The previous one y was
useful coming backwards.
If we're going to go forward,
let me define a matrix, P,
where the ij-th element is a
partial xi, partial alpha i.
If I have that and I
want to take gradients
with respect to this, then I can
do it pretty easily actually.
If I want to do partial
J partial alpha,
I can go inside the integral.
It's just dt.
I'm just using my
chain rule here.
I get partial G, partial x,
partial x, partial alpha.
These are x at some time
T, plus partial G partial
U at time T, partial
pi, partial alpha.
And in general, if I have a
feedback term in my policy,
I also got to worry
about partial G,
partial U, partial pi, partial
x, partial x, partial alpha.
It's just a chain rule
derivative of this.
Do you agree?
It turns out, using
the matrices we
had used before, I can write
that very simply as integral
from 0 to T of Gx, the big
derivative of x times P,
this matrix here, plus the
big derivative of G on alpha.
If we know partial x of t
partial alpha, then it's easy.
So how do we get partial
x T partial alpha?
Well, that's easy too.
Let's look at the
forward equation
here, xu which is, in this
case, pi alpha x of T.
So let's look at how
this changes with alpha.
Let's take the derivative
with respect to alpha.
I'll write it even
more cleanly--
partial f, partial
x plus partial f,
partial U, partial pi, partial
x times P, which is partial
x, partial alpha.
Let me write it as--
Everybody agree with
that chain rule?
No?
OK, ask me.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there you
have G with respect
to x and then P
[INAUDIBLE] And then
we have G of alpha which
would be the second variable.
What happened in the third one?
RUSS TEDRAKE: G of x is
actually partial G partial x
plus partial U--
G partial U, partial
pi, partial x.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's the big
gradient with respect to x.
AUDIENCE: And that I on the
bottom is J. Is that correct?
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: This
is now the matrix P.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Oh, thank you.
That should be a
J on the bottom.
Good, thank you.
Please do catch me
on those things.
Yeah, thank you.
So then, are we happy with this?
So this is pretty simple too.
Just now, I get an
equation forward
in the gradients P
dot is my big f of x.
Which I get is the direct
and the indirect gradient
with respect to x times P plus
the gradient of F with respect
to alpha.
And that's it.
I'm almost waiting
for more to do, right?
So if you're willing to go--
if you want to go
forward in time, then
if you're willing to keep around
this extra term, partial x
partial alpha, then as
you move forward in time,
you can build up your gradient
of partial J partial alpha.
And by the time you
get to the end of time,
you don't have to
go backwards again.
You know what the
total derivative is.
So why would you use this
versus the other method?
Does everybody agree with that?
I don't see big smiles, but
this is satisfying and simple--
smile.
The cost of this is
carrying around this matrix.
So potentially,
that could be big.
If you have a lot of
parameters, let's say
I have 100 parameters
in my control system,
or 10,000 parameters
then you're actually integrating
forward a matrix equation
that could be pretty big.
It's something that's x--
the dimension of x by
the number of parameters.
So that's one-- that's really
the only problem with it.
The back prop
through time is only
carrying around this y,
which is the size of x.
But to do this sort of nice
forward-backward update,
you'd better be able to
remember the trajectory
that x has taken over time.
So for very long
trajectories, it
might not be much more
efficient to do this.
It's just a trade-off.
Some problems are actually
quite nicely done in RTRL.
Some are nicely done with
back prop through time.
The back prop through
time is, the reason
it's so beautiful
and clean is that--
so remembering your goal here is
to compute a vector, partial J,
which J is a scalar with respect
to a vector of parameters.
Here you have to carry around
a matrix to do that, partial x
forward.
The back prop through time
takes advantage of the fact
that at the end of
time, everything
collapses to a scalar again.
And that's why it only has
to sort of carry backwards.
If you willing to go all
the way to the end of time,
you can remember only the
effect of that scalar value, j,
with respect to the x's.
So that's why you're allowed
to carry around less of this.
But it involves going
forward and backwards.
Is that intuitive?
Yeah?
What can I say more?
There's various
other reasons why you
might prefer one or the other.
So for instance, let's
say you have a final--
a boundary condition.
Let's say you want to
solve this constraint,
minimize this function
subject to the constraint
that x of capital T is my goal.
You can write that constraint
into either of them.
I find it more natural to
write it into this RTRL form.
Just because you know explicitly
partial x, partial alpha.
So if you want to
compute at the end
your constraint derivatives,
saying what should I have done?
How should I have
changed alpha in order
to enforce that constraint?
Then it's actually a
simple function of P.
So maybe I'm not giving
you a silver bullet
by telling you one
way or the other.
But depending on exactly the
way you want to use them,
sometimes one is more
useful than the other.
So in the simulations
I'm about to show you,
I'm going to actually RTRL,
just because it's also,
this is trivial to code.
But the big idea here
is really just that I'm
doing a shooting method.
I'm simulating
this thing forward.
And I'm trying to compute
what's the change.
And that's my scalar
cost with respect
to a change in my parameters.
So that I can then
update my parameters.
And last time, we talked about
multiple ways to do that.
You might do that with a simple
gradient descent algorithm.
You could do gradient descent.
You could say that
alpha at the n plus 1
step is just alpha n minus
some learning rate, eta,
times partial J partial alpha.
And I argued last time
that you can do better
than that by sequential
quadratic programming.
To the point where SQP methods
are so robust that you just
find something like SNOPT, you
download it, and you use it.
And I'll try to convince you
as we run some of these things
that apart from installing
a package, which
takes a few minutes,
once you do it,
you'll never go back to this.
I'll tell you one reason
right off the bat.
Choosing the learning rate
is a pain in the butt.
You never have to do it again.
So?
Let's see some examples.
Let me do the
pendulum with SNOPT.
So using SNOPT is just,
all you do is you tell it--
you give it a function
which can compute J and J,
the derivatives of J. It's
SNOPT stood for sparse nonlinear
optimal--
or optimization.
And in a lot of
problems, many elements
of this vector, partial
J partial alpha, are 0.
We're going to see that in our
direct collocation methods.
A lot of those gradients are 0.
It happens in the
one I just told you.
This is typically not--
typically all of those
elements of that vector
are non-zero, which
means I'm not actually
getting an advantage
by using the sparse.
NPSOL is the non-sparse version.
But I don't think it's
much worse, if any worse.
Just for those of
you that are trying
to figure out which
package you want
to convince your PI to buy.
I think SNOPT is
normally pretty good.
And there's a student
version that we
can have you download
that'll do small problems.
So let's do the pendulum.
My cost function here,
is just an LQR cost.
I have Q as a--
I have J as the integral
from 0 to capital T
of x minus the x goal.
I had to be careful
about wrapping.
But transpose Q x minus x
goal plus u transpose Ru.
The whole thing, dt, right?
And I actually also have a final
value cost where Q is 10, 1.
Qf is 100 times
that or something.
Q and R is 100.
So it's going to reward the
thing for getting to the top.
Let's see what it does.
I'm going to plot the
trajectory for every step
of the optimization.
So it's not quite doing
simple gradient descent.
It's now going to do
a sequential quadratic
programming update where it
estimates the quadratic bowl
and tries to jump right to
the minimum of the bowl.
So it's going to be a little
bit more jumpy, as you see it,
but it's fast.
It's finding the last
optimization and then
boop, right to the top.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So how is this
trajectory parameterized?
Is it just openly.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It's exactly
this, the floor of T over dt.
My sloppy notation was
because it's MATLAB notation.
AUDIENCE: So when
they say [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: That's
the open-loop policy,
which had U at time T,
was just, I do a floor,
and I go to the
n-th index in alpha.
So alpha 1 is my control
action from 0 to dt.
AUDIENCE: So how many
parameters is this case?
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
So I did two seconds
covered by 40 bins.
I bet if I do 20 bins, it's OK.
It may be a little
less faithful to the--
less smooth.
But it works out.
So please realize that
like 60% of that time
was just drawing those plots
to the screen, easily, right?
Especially when it's reshaping
the screen and stuff like that.
That's wasted time.
So hey, we could do the same
thing on the [? karpal. ?]
AUDIENCE: Can we do this
without [INAUDIBLE]??
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good question.
Yes.
So yes, it's quite simple.
In direct collocation,
it's really simple.
So actually, my code does
it for direct collocation
and doesn't do it
for the gradient.
But it's actually quite fine.
You just have to have T as
one of your parameters tucked
into alpha and be
able to compute
partial J, partial T, which
is not very hard actually.
You just have to figure out
how this function changes when
you take a derivative with
respect to T. And it's just,
it's like an x dot
times the quantity J
at T. It's not too bad.
If you can take that gradient,
you can optimize with respect
to it.
So what about for the
[? card pull? ?] Well, oh I
forgot, I took off the zooming.
So I gave it a fixed axis.
It's going to make
a liar out of me.
This is the slowest I've seen.
There it is.
Let me do that again.
It's certainly more
impressive than that.
It's starting from random
initial tapes, by the way.
And every time I've run it
for the [? card pull, ?]
it comes up with
the same solution.
Come on.
There we go.
All right, not quite
as impressive as it
was in the lab, but
that's still pretty good.
If I turn off drawing,
it bet it's a lot faster.
So I turned off
drawing, there you go.
I think my computer is
slower on battery power too.
That's probably--
I'm disappointed.
Oh well, it's still pretty fast.
AUDIENCE: So I was
just wondering,
if you simulated longer,
would it stay at the top,
or would it fall in?
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I actually
put a final value constraint in
on that.
So it actually gets to 0, 0.
So because I'm simulating, it
probably would stay up, right?
But I think the
natural thing to do
would be to draw
an LQR controller
in at the top for instance.
And in fact, we're
going to talk on Tuesday
about how to LQR stabilize
that whole trajectory.
Because for the most part,
I think open-loop is just
the first piece of the--
just is one of the tools.
Good.
So what happens if we did--
you can do the acrobot too.
I'll do the acrobot
in a second here.
But I also have the sort of
simple gradient [? descent ?]
version in here.
That if I just did
my alpha equals
negative eta times dJ d alpha in
there, let's see how that does.
Was that faster?
Let's do it.
Let me try that again.
That's not running.
I didn't save it.
I knew that was too
good to be true.
OK, my ears are too big.
I probably have to
change my learning rate.
Thereby confirming
my complaint that--
OK, so it works.
But never do it again,
you don't need to.
Just download SNOPT.
It'll get there eventually.
You can see the
errors going down.
And if I set my
learning rate properly,
it'll go down pretty fast.
But not fast enough
for me to be patient.
And then, here's the
SNOPT version again.
Now the pendulum is very fast.
Good.
Let me do direct collocation
before we get too mystified
by the simulations.
There's another idea.
So shooting methods
are certainly
subject to local minima.
And I've got an example that
I'll show you in a few minutes
that I hope will make
that clear why they
can be subject to local minima.
Something that people
do, they do sometimes
multiple shooting methods.
Sometimes it's sort of, there's
even numerical sensitivity
sometimes, sort of integrating
this thing for such
a long time.
So a lot of times, people
will define some breakpoint
in the middle of there,
some artificial breakpoint
in the middle of
their trajectory.
And say, I'm going
to optimize, first
try to get me to this point.
And then I'll say if I simulated
from some other point to here
and then use as a constraint
in their optimization
to try to make that residual
go to 0, if that makes sense.
I'm just not going to talk
about multiple shooting.
But just know that there's a
version that people use often,
which are the multiple
shooting methods.
To some extent,
direct collocation
is maybe the extreme of that.
I told you there's a
lot of good reasons
to use SNOPT, or some SQP.
So first of all, why use SNOPT?
No learning rate tweaking,
that's a big one for me.
It's often faster convergence.
Because you are doing big steps.
You can sometimes jump
over small local minima.
But there's a big one in there
that's not on the list yet.
What's the big one
I'm going to say?
What's perhaps the best
reason, I think, to use SNOPT?
AUDIENCE: Fewer constraints?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Good.
It's easy to add constraints.
Because the way these
sequential programs are solved,
there with these interior point
methods and things like this.
And they're very efficient
at handling constraints.
So in my pendulum swing up on
the simple gradient descent,
I didn't actually have
a final constraint
on getting to the top
in the SNOPT version.
It's just trivial to add that.
I can put bounds on my
actions very easily.
I could say, do
gradient descent,
but never let U at time
T be bigger than 5.
I can even put constraints on
the trajectory if I wanted to.
So because of the power
of nonlinear optimization
to handle constraints, people
came up with a different way
to hand the optimal control
problem to an SQP method
that exploits those
constraint-solving abilities
a little bit more explicitly.
And that's the direct
collocation methods.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
couple of questions?
When we were talking
about this previous case
that you showed, isn't
it just providing
the [INAUDIBLE] function,
providing the Q's and R's is
sufficient to actually
get [INAUDIBLE]..
So if we add an R
constraint on top of it,
it would be [INAUDIBLE]
on top and sort
of like a 2 with
respect to our method?
Because the goal
we have essentially
is to maximize or
minimize the [INAUDIBLE]
over the trajectory.
We can put some content, like
it would be more information.
Like for example, I wanted to
reach this state or that state
for sure.
We [INAUDIBLE].
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I think
that's a very RL way
to think about it--
not cheating.
I mean, cheat, cheating is good.
If you can hand more information
to your algorithm, do it.
Don't worry about cheating.
But no, I agree.
So the question was, is it
fair to give it a final value
constraint, or am I comparing
apples and oranges, roughly,
right?
Like if I say one is not using
the final value constraint
and the other one is.
So in my opinion, the goal is
actually to get there at time
T. The optimal control
program I'd like to solve
is minimize some, even
minimizing just u transpose Ru
dt subject to x of t is my goal.
That might be my favorite
way to write it down.
And then, just the
question is, what methods
can I use to solve that?
So the opposite
view of the world
here maybe is that because
a lot of the methods
don't handle these
constraints explicitly,
I'm stuck writing down
a cost function, which
is x transpose Qx
plus u transpose Ru,
even if that's not
explicitly what I want.
Or maybe I should say,
especially the closest analogy
is if I have a final
value cost, straight
and maybe I make Qf really big.
The only question is what
you really want to do.
In most cases, I
really want to do that.
So I'm quite happy
to use solvers
which could do either case.
I think a more
powerful solver is one
that can handle either case.
AUDIENCE: The other
question is, if we
want to solve something
which takes a lot of time,
like T is relatively
big, it seems
that if this open-loop policy
thing that you're following
has one parameter per time step.
RUSS TEDRAKE: It could
have a lot of parameters.
Good.
AUDIENCE: But is it
possible to just describe
the whole policy with
a very limited space
with very few parameters
and solve for that?
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I tried
to be careful to write down
the equations.
So the question was--
can people hear the
question or not?
The question was
roughly that if we're
worried about a problem with
a very long horizon time,
it seems that I
might have to have
a very large list of
parameters to cover-- to make
a tape that's that long.
And so, aren't the algorithms
rather inefficient there?
Couldn't I do better by writing
down maybe a feedback policy?
That's often the case is
that feedback policies can
be more compact.
So I tried to write
down all these equations
as if there was some dependence
on x in your policy too.
So the equations will be the
same if you do that version.
The only thing that
I don't handle nicely
in the things I'm
throwing up on the board
is that I'm always
simulating from the same x0.
So I'm really
explicitly optimizing,
even if I optimize a
feedback controller
from a single initial
condition, its performance
from a single initial condition.
So you can quite easily
say make a different cost
function, which is,
let's say I want
J to be the sum
of my performance
from initial conditions
K through 100.
And this would be,
let's say, J of xk, 0,
or something like this.
Maybe I could start
it from 100 of
my favorite initial conditions.
And that would try to optimize a
feedback policy perhaps better.
But the only thing that's not
nicely addressed, I think,
is choosing your initial
conditions in a nice way.
DP-- [INAUDIBLE] program
handles that beautifully.
And these things are
much more local methods.
So they have to be in there.
But I absolutely agree.
Oftentimes, the open-loop tapes
are not a particularly sparse
way to parameterize a policy.
Good.
So the direct collocation
methods, like I said,
more explicitly--
they're even more
in the sense of open-loop
policies versus feedback
policies, actually.
But they also more explicitly
add these constraints.
So here's the idea.
Let's make my alpha
my vector that I'm
trying to optimize over.
A list of, can I
call it u0, u1, u2--
is that another reasonable way
to describe what I've already
done--
to u capital N. I've got
a list of control actions.
But now I'm going
to actually also,
I'm going to augment my
parameter vector with the state
vector.
So I'm just going to make an
even bigger parameter vector.
One of the reasons
to do that is,
I can now evaluate J of alpha,
which is this 0 to T, G of x.
Maybe I even approximated
this discretization, right?
So it could have a
dt in there or not,
it doesn't matter to me.
If I have u and x
and all these things
directly in my
parameter vector, I
don't actually need to simulate
in order to evaluate that.
I can just evaluate
it immediately.
I have x and I have u.
The only problem is
that how do I pick alpha
so that x and u are consistent?
It better be the
case that x1 looks
like the integration
of x0 with u0
applied had better get me to x1.
So instead of having that sort
of implicit in my equations,
let's make it an
explicit constraint.
So let's do this subject to the
constraint that x of N plus 1--
actually, lots of constraints,
so it's a list of constraints.
x1 had better be f of x0
u0 times dt, let's say.
It had better be equal to
0, and so on, then x2--
right?
So if I'm willing to
add representation here,
I can actually evaluate
my cost function
without explicitly simulating.
That's cool.
I can take gradients
very quickly,
because now it's just
explicitly the gradients,
partial G, partial x.
Well, I know x, right?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
you also want x1
minus f of x0 u0 dt minus x0?
[INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: Yes, thank you.
Thank you.
So plus-- thank you.
Good, thank you.
I had some weird
mix of discrete time
and continuous time
floating around there.
So if you parameterize
it like this,
you can very efficiently
calculate the gradients.
For instance, whereas
you can easily
calculate the
gradient with respect
to time, in this
parameterization,
and you just add a lot of
constraints to your solver.
And you're asking your solver
to solve for a lot more points.
It turns out that these
solvers handle constraints
very efficiently.
In fact, it's often
times more efficient
to add constraints
to the system,
because it reduces
the search space.
So this is actually quite fast.
The only criticism of it--
then there's another thing nice
thing about it is that you can--
I'll show you what
I mean by this.
But you can sort
of initialize this
in ways that hop out
of other local minima.
So let's say I just choose
my initial conditions
in the previous simulations.
I just always just
chose u0 to [? uN ?]
to be some small random number.
So the pendulum
in the first thing
would just shake
here a little bit.
And then it quickly changed
until it swung up to the top.
I can pick x perhaps
more intelligently.
It won't have satisfied
the constraints
in the initial case.
But I can choose an x.
For the pendulum, let's
say my initial guess
at x would be a direct
trajectory that goes straight
up to the top.
If I start searching now for
alphas that minimize this cost
and satisfy those
constraints, it just
puts me in a different sort
of area of the search space.
And it might actually help me
find the swing of policies.
It's a very sort of
heuristic thing to say.
But it makes a big difference
in practice I find.
So I think most people
today actually use
these direct collocation methods
for trajectory optimization.
Yeah, Rick?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
change those parameters
the vector would change.
RUSS TEDRAKE: So you're
worried that this will change--
the constraint
matrix would change?
AUDIENCE: Well, aside
of the alpha [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: So I don't
do it that way in my code.
I do it, I say that this is
valid from 0 to T over N,
let's say.
And this one is used from T
over N to 2T over N and so on.
So it just stretches out.
So the dt is not constant.
I use that same action for
longer if my T stretches out.
And that keeps the
parameter vector constant.
But I think if you were
to purchase a DIRCOL--
this is often shorthand as
DIRCOL, direct collocation,
DIRCOL.
And there was a DIRCOL
package that you
could get in
FORTRAN 10 years ago
or something that I think
a lot of people used.
And I think those do things
like it stretches out time.
And then if dt gets ridiculous,
it adds some more points.
And then a more polished
software package
would do these things
like adding parameters
and then reinitialize--
reseeding the optimization.
Mine doesn't.
Should I show you how it works?
Is that the best
thing to do here?
It's a pretty simple idea.
The part that I can't
really express to you
efficiently here is why
that this is something
that the solvers
can do very well.
I can tell you that it's about
how SQPs do interior point
methods, but I don't
want to get into that.
So I think if you just sort of
take it on faith that they're
good at handling
constraints, I think
it's reasonable to
think that maybe sending
in an over-defined trajectory
and allowing it to sort out
the constraints is a
reasonable thing to try.
And in practice, let me tell
you that it's pretty fast.
So can I do the
pendulum DIRCOL now?
So that one was fast before.
Now you notice the
time horizon here--
3.06?
Yeah, so that's what
it wanted to be doing.
It liked 3.06 better than two.
So maybe my other
ones would work
better if I put 3 in there.
Can we do the--
someone called for the acrobot
before, DIRCOL on the acrobot.
Oh, I should turn off plotting.
Sorry.
Let's see what happens.
It's also got this
final value constraint.
That's why it quickly
got to the goal
to satisfy that constraint.
And now it's making sure
that all the dynamics
that these trajectories
are satisfied.
And then, it's just optimizing
within that constraint
manifold.
I didn't really mean to--
I'm afraid to hit
Control-C. It might crash.
That's the one thing about
[? SNAP ?] being a [? MEX ?]
package calling FORTRAN--
stop.
now my GUI is gone
and my code is gone.
Great.
OK, good.
And it got to the top.
No, that's the pendulum, sorry.
That's cheating.
So turning off printing, just
run DIRCOL for a second here.
AUDIENCE: How would
using these methods can
be extended to stochastic case?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think
they're heavily tuned
to the deterministic case.
I won't make a blanket statement
saying they can't be extended.
But even the feedback--
I really think the direct
collocation in particular
feels very specialized
for opening
the trajectory optimization.
This is slower than I remember.
It gets there.
Yeah, John.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a reason why you
need to use [INAUDIBLE] vector
and not feedback [INAUDIBLE]..
You could evaluate the u given
the x and the [INAUDIBLE]..
RUSS TEDRAKE: I think
you could do that.
I think the key thing
is parameterizing
the policy as well as x.
But I think you're right.
If you did some handful of
w's or alphas there-- sorry--
then I think you could
probably do that too, yeah.
I mean, implementing this
constraint is the only
real criticism that people
have of collocation methods.
Almost everybody
uses them, it seems.
The only criticism
they have is that they
have sort of this fixed-step
integration in here.
The constraint being satisfied--
it's hard to do sort of an
ODE solver in that step,
because you need
to be able to take
the gradients of
your constraint.
So they tend to be fixed-step
integration routines, roughly.
And so, the accuracy--
if people point to a problem
with collocation methods,
they uniformly say that
they're not as accurate
as the shooting methods, because
you don't actually numerically
simulate your system carefully.
You've picked some time
discretization of the system,
and you get it right for that.
But I don't think that's
a big deal actually.
And if they're fast and they
get out of local minima,
then worst case, solve
it this way and then
do a little shooting
method at the end
to finish the
optimization, if you like.
Run it one more time.
John and I were
talking before class
that there's really
no reason why
you couldn't compute
the gradients of an ODE,
update inside here.
Well, how would you do that?
You do it exactly like we did
the shooting method, right?
You could sort of run a little--
to compute the gradients
of your constraint,
you could actually
do the adjoint method
or the RTRL method to
compute those gradients.
And then, that
puts you somewhere
in the land between
direct collocation
and multiple shooting.
I swear that my laptop must
be operating on half a brain
right now, because this
was much faster in lab.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have a power cord?
RUSS TEDRAKE: I'm not
connected into power.
AUDIENCE: If you
go to the battery,
I guess it switches
to energy saver.
RUSS TEDRAKE:
Yeah, you're right.
I could probably turn
it off right now.
So that was a slightly
different trajectory.
That's just graphics though.
I'd be exceptionally
embarrassed if I
plugged it in or changed
the power settings
and it was still slow.
So let me just say that
it was faster in live
and we'll leave it like that.
So let me just
make the point of,
do people understand how
a problem like this--
we sort of saw a demonstration
that, if you could remember
in your head what
the acrobot did
the first time and the
acrobot did the second time.
They both got to the
goal pretty well.
They took slightly different
trajectories, at least
to my eye.
So one of the
complaints about any
of these trajectory
optimization methods
is, they're only local methods.
We're only going to find a
local optima in my optimization.
For me, I think about
these problems a lot.
It's still not
completely intuitive
what you think of a local minima
in these settings might be.
There are some places where
it could be pretty intuitive.
So the pendulum, you can imagine
if I found one policy that
pumped up with one
pump, you could
imagine it might be hard to sort
of get over a cost landscape,
so you did two pumps to get up.
That could be a case where
a local minima makes sense.
I tried to come up with a little
bit more obvious of an example
here relating to the original
grid world stuff we did.
So now, this isn't so
much a dynamics problem.
But I thought maybe a
path-planning problem
would make the point.
So here's a random geometric
landscape with Gaussian bumps
that you try to avoid
or you incur cost.
I'm actually plotting the cost
landscape as a function of x.
So you see there's a small hill,
which is trying to take me down
to the goal in red.
Can I turn the lights all the
way down for a minute here?
It'll be dramatic this way.
So there's a goal here in red.
And let's say the
initial conditions
are over there in green.
And your task is to
take the system, which
is x dot equals u, where x
is the xy position of this,
and u is the velocity
in x, the velocity in y.
So just a trivial
dynamical system,
but you're trying to
find a path that gets you
to the goal with minimal cost.
So I did this example just
because some people care
about this kind of example.
But also because I think it's
sort of critically obvious
how you can have local minima.
If I get a trajectory that's
on one side of the mountain
and maybe the globally
optimal trajectory
is on the other side
of the mountain,
it might be hard for me
to get across the mountain
to that trajectory.
So let's just see that happen.
So do direct collocation
here, so what did I implement?
OK, so I forgot to type--
so I just did
direct collocation.
And really quickly,
it found this.
So this is not the
optimization software's fault.
What if I do this?
So it found some nice
path through the foothills
here to the goal.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: Can you try to
specify some of those--
since you have x
parameterized, can you
try to make it go through
a particular set of bumps
by specifying that?
RUSS TEDRAKE: Exactly.
So the reason I chose
to do direct collocation
for this is, my initial guess,
u was just some random vector.
But my x was actually a direct
line from start to the goal.
AUDIENCE: So if you
had drawn it as a line
between those first two and
then going around to [INAUDIBLE]
RUSS TEDRAKE: So the
one I thought to do was,
let's just do-- just because
it was easy to type--
let's do an initial x which
just goes directly this way
and then see what happens.
I think that's what I had here.
So if I change my x tape
here is now linspace.
So it interpolates in
x0 straight to the goal.
But then the other one is
just x1 straight across,
reading that code is not what
you want to do in class here.
But if I set the initial x tape
to be that and I run it again,
It's doing its solving.
It's properly doing
it in some window.
Oh, I turned off
animation, didn't I?
Oops, that was a failure.
But it found a different path.
But it actually told
me, Warning, exited.
So I have this check
page 19 of [INAUDIBLE] 6
the paper to figure out
what the heck exit 41 means.
But it basically couldn't
satisfy the constraints.
So I bet if I just run it
again with the random initial
conditions, it'll be OK.
But the point is exactly this.
I still found one
that just probably
didn't satisfy some of the
constraints at some small part
of that trajectory here.
It went the other way
around the mountain.
So there are local
minima in these problems.
In problems like this,
it's completely obvious
why there are local minima.
In the acrobot and
things like that,
you will find that
there are local minima.
If you start with different
random parameterizations,
you'll find slightly different
swing-up trajectories.
So our local minima--
a killer-- a lot of
people say, well,
that means these methods stink.
They're subject to local minima.
I don't care if I'm in a local
minima for the most part.
I mean, if I was really
going to have to walk around
a mountain instead of walking
through the mountains,
then maybe I'd care.
But if I'm doing an
acrobot and it swings up
like this instead of swings up
like this, for the most part,
I don't care.
So although people
talk about it a lot,
I find in most of the
problems I care about,
local minima aren't
that big of a deal.
They exist.
Sometimes they can
upset your numerics.
But as long as you get
to the goal, I'm happy.
Now, there are a
couple other ideas
in these trajectory
optimizations.
And on Tuesday, I guess, I'm
going to wait till Tuesday now,
first of all, I'm
going to tell you
how to stabilize
these trajectories.
Because that's useless
as it is right now.
If I just even simulated
it with a different dt,
it would probably fall or
not get to the mountain.
But it turns out, even
with a pretty coarse time
step, if you stabilize
the thing with feedback,
then it works great.
So I'll show you how to do
the trajectory stabilization
with an LQR method on Tuesday.
And that's actually
going to lead
to another class of the
trajectory optimizers, which
would be an
iterative LQR method.
And then, depending on how
much I sleep this weekend,
I was thinking about doing
the discrete mechanics
version of the trajectory
optimizers on Tuesday too.
We'll see.
So we'll push the walking
back until Thursday
just to complete the story about
these trajectories solvers.
Any Questions?
They're pretty good.
They're pretty fast,
especially if you
are plugged into the wall.
OK, see you see you next week.